[Applaudissements]
sa maman chérie ça va très bien on en
parlait ce matin de plus en plus beau
toit ah bon je vous jure que c'est vrai
tout comme ça c'est gentil bien ses
chaussures reçu son conseiller beauté
c'est vrai c'est vrai ici en face à une
formation d'art cas et stylisme avec de
plus en plus vous remercie beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de photos de justin
même qui peut là c'est ce qui va se
passer c'est la prochaine vous êtes la
barbière de paris c'est sale c'est la
barrière de paris bercy il est parti au
paris volley est pourquoi vous voulez
pas faire un spectacle parce qu'on ne
savait pas qu'on fasse un jour un
spectacle d'isabelle assez en première
partie pour être sûr que ça marche pas
du tout mettra maxime on et non pas à
laisser partir alors pour commencer
voici une nouvelle preuve que cyril
hanouna est le plus grand spécialiste
médias parce qu'il sait d'avancé une
émission va fonctionner ou non sa
véritable médium exact regardez tous
dans la boule de baba kane matin
tranquille tu va cartonner
ça n'a pas du tout marché
et oui c'est ça de connaître par coeur
et quelques jours après on apprend
carrément ceux-ci se connaissent tous
avec moi
dell s'il est déjà déprogrammée
[Applaudissements]
gentil mari mais c'est vrai mais bon
chez je voulais tellement que ça marche
pour eric ress que je l'adoré mais ça
voilà ce parent doit irriguer n'a pas
trouvé son public alors il ya un camp à
cachottier parmi vous non y'a un
cachottier parmi vous quelqu'un qui joue
actuellement dans le nouveau feuilleton
star en algérie et qui s'est bien gardé
de nous le dire et ça j'aime pas du tout
ça s'appelle alors est ce par les mâles
accents vlad la loge pas comme on dit et
vous allez immédiatement reconnaître
quelqu'un qui est en ce moment même sur
ce plateau c'est le laurier du gars qui
pensaient qu'on allait pas grillé mais
on ne la fait pas à moi
[Applaudissements]
c'est le même gars même très dangereux
chutant les choux oui on attendait le
regard également mais tout tout tout et
tout c'est le choc
zizi les mêmes usines selon lui car
scène entièrement en algérie pour le
ramadan mais bon franchement bas soit la
cie si un jour il est pas là où pour me
demander exact je serai la russie alors
touche pas à mon poste est devenue
l'émission qui a en plateau le plus de
gens schlumpf jeunes en plus des objets
uniques ou en dix jours on allume hier
frei on et geneviève de fontenay et les
frères bogdanoff away les adore elles
sont magnifiques les frères bogdanov qui
et quand ils prennent le train réserve
quatre places 2 pour eux deux pour le
montant je sais et dont quelques minutes
vous serez qu'ils étaient lus tard baba
cette semaine mais cyril avec ce que
vous l'auriez balancer hier soir vont
apporter quoi qu'il arrive aux lauriers
c'est clair du thar bogda oui je l'adoré
on s'adore mais oui mais c'est là un
chantier bien bas en été
[Musique]
ce qui avec les bogdanoff c'est que les
blagues sur où ils n'ont jamais plaint
le menton est ce qu'ils veulent au
périgord
merci avec ça vous fait un pari monde
c'est repenser terry gou venu d'une
autre planète dont ils ont fait des
expériences sur vous ça ne l'avait
jamais dit dans mon tonus jamais
suffisante il aurait sorti lauréat de
sciences po battue je vais avoir le
menton fille raconte
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment des produits c'est connu
c'est aussi connu leur grichka je vous
jure que c'est connu qu'il design on
s'est connu à un concours de jeux de
tiens tu me tiens par la barbichette
croire antoine heerah continue à parler
des bogdanov parce que lire dans la
mission vous avez été plusieurs à
affirmer que l'on est chroniqueur
ressemblait beaucoup au fait un bond de
9,1 à 10 il change de numéro de
téléphone aussi ça ne changeait pas
alors juste redire mes enfants on dit
que vous essayez le plus beau de
l'émission domino en reine des neiges
qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est que 2000 les
enfants qu'on dise ah bah oui bafoue les
enfants saison pour les amener chez
petits lots annoncés l'année prochaine
ça va avoir beaucoup de temps vous allez
pouvoir alors je remet à benjamin
castadi le laurier le gars qui est
dégoûté de ressemble ou bogdanov et
franchement je comprend pas pourquoi je
trouve quelque chose
regardez de montmagny
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pu l'atteindre en direct je vais
dire un truc d'ofer tourisme m
c'est pas fini c'est fini parce que
benjamin castaldi certains ici
prétendent donc vous ressemblez mots
qu'on fabrique de 9 alors j'ai mis les
plus grands scientifiques sur le coup
pour vérifier si oui ou non vous aviez
un lien de parenté
vous connaissez tous la fameuse frise de
de l'évolution de l'homme voyez bien sûr
je ne suis procuré la toute dernière
version que l'université de pennsylvanie
m'a envoyé et benjamin j'ai bien peur
que la réponse nous fasse pas plaisir
c'est une véritable avancée scientifique
dans cette nouvelle crise on découvre
qu'après le singe jammer castaldi tué
benjamin castaldi puis igor bogdanoff et
enfin grichka bogdanoff après cette
preuve scientifique gmo menjivar encore
n'y est évidemment alors voici une
preuve irréfutable
quand il est maquillée benjamin castaldi
ne ressemble pas à un bogdan ordination
que non mais son maquillage je crois
qu'il ne peux plus mentir
[Applaudissements]
je rappelle benjamin vous et votre papa
vous êtes très beaux bons joueurs et je
le dis moi j'ai un il est redevenu opus
encore plus beau qu'avant moi j'en ai
deux centraux pharma valérie part il est
beau est nominé pour y sortir avec lui
trois belges il adore soirée dans un
instant qui est sorti avec une star
internationale
c'est un truc de fou moi ça m'a c'est un
truc de malade à vous rassurer parce que
j'ai vraiment travaillé avec plaisir
avec plaisir alors pour finir il est
temps de mettre fin au suspense
insoutenable qui vous empêche de dormir
chaque semaine qui a été élue tard baba
est allé plus traiter ses collègues via
le plus tacler ses collègues du dialogue
c'est le septième c'est le septième tard
bob
pour l'instant j'en avais gagné 6 à
révision passe à cette eau qui est plus
t'as qu'à ses collègues est ce que cyril
hanouna conserve son titre pour la
septième semaine d'affilée leuthard baba
de la semaine et cyril hanouna
[Applaudissements]
et s'il vous plaît merci ce que vous
voulez dire qu'est ce qu'on m'a dit on
loge tout à l'heure ouais est ce qu'on a
dit on lofteurs parce que je veux dit
aux téléspectateurs soit 10 en loge tout
à l'heure alors mois ferme ta gueule
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant tu dors la nuit obbadi on va
dire quelques heures deux trois heures
par semaine
tu dors plus pendant l'émission c'est
qu'on a tous les trois la même passion
qui me gêne pas les annonces là bas bien
sûr c'est pas les mariages comme toi
[Applaudissements]
bravo pour tout ce que tu fais vraiment
et je trouve que tu as ta place dans
cette émission c'est pas pour combien de
temps mais tu as ta place
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que magali peuvent nous faire une
faveur et parler avec sa voix danette
ah non tu dis moi ce que tu peux me
faire une faveur et quitter le plateau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est fait